je comprends que des canadiens qui ont
épargné longtemps pour acheter des
billets d'avion qui leur sont très chers
et nous allons travailler avec
l'industrie nous sommes en train de
regarder ce que d'autres compagnies
aériennes font à à travers le monde et
nous allons avoir plus à dire dans les
semaines à venir
deux invités pour en parler ce soir de
cette question du remboursement des
billets d'avion et lise thériault est
avocate chez option consommateurs et
myron et brahimi et directeur de
l'observatoire international de
l'aéronautique de l'aviation civile
civils à vous deux bonsoir bonsoir il y
ferait rio d'abord je vais vous demander
est ce que vous sentez que la pression
qui est de plus en plus forte quand même
pour le roi en faveur du remboursement
des billets d'avion est ce que vous
sentez que la pression est en train de
faire fléchir le gouvernement du canada
et les compagnies aériennes
j'aimerais bien avoir une boule de
cristal pour vous répondre mais on
espère très fort que oui étant donné que
non seulement une question d'équité
mais c'est également la loi de
rembourser et les gens quand on peut pas
fournir le service mais vous dites que
c'est la loi mais si c'était si clair
que c'est la loupe le premier ministre
trudeau l'imposerait vous pensez pas en
fait et où québec
notre code civil prévoit que en matière
de force majeure quand un contractant
peut pas fournir sa part du contrat et
en raison de la force majeure il ya
aucune équivoque ça doit être le
rembourser je pense que ce n'est pas une
question de légalité l'hésitation de
monsieur trudeau là ça va être plutôt
une question de trouver l'équilibré
selon lui entre les besoins de
l'industrie et les droits des
consommateurs et donc ça m'amène à vous
demander mehran ebrahimi est ce que les
compagnies aériennes sont capables de
rembourser financièrement je dirais avec
la question n'est pas là moi je suis un
partisan fervent défenseur de l'aide des
états aux compagnies aériennes
aujourd'hui toutes les compagnies
aériennes le monde sont en situation de
faillite potentielle et tous les pays du
monde
pratiquement l'europe l'australie les
etats-unis ils ont entravé sont en train
d'aider massivement
les compagnies air elle ça c'est une
chose mais il faut pas oublier qu'au
moment où un passager achète un billet
d'avant ce le transfert de risque de la
compagnie aérienne va sur le dos du
passager autrement dit moyennant une
réduction de tarif vous achetez un
billet dans trois quatre cinq mois et là
à ce moment là la compagnie aérienne est
sûr que son avion sera remplie il
rappelé donc et tunnels de passagers
achètent moins cher de le compagnie
aérienne a sûrement un christ alors
aujourd'hui on est dans une situation où
les passagers ont assumé ce fardeau de
risque et en plus il peut pas avoir le
service est donc ça c'est c'est injuste
en fait à tous les ans toutes situations
c'est le passager qui finalement qui
aiderait triplement pénalisé risque pas
de transfert de risque
deuxièmement les états par le biais des
transferts pas que ça le siba soit sur
le salaire ou dans le pays où on aide
les compagnies aériennes
donc ils financent finalement le connaît
et le film troisième fois ils sont
pénalisés parce que le biais qu'ils ont
achetés
c'est donc il n'ya pas de service mais
pour eux ce n'est pas sérieux
autrement dit les bases les passagers
double de finances doublement les
compagnies aériennes ce qui est
complètement inconcevable aujourd'hui
quand on regarde comment les arrêts dont
il ya un devoir moral des compagnies
aériennes de rembourser les billets
c'est un peu sa hausse tout à fait
exactement moral est tout à fait tout à
fait chez option consommateurs et lise
thériault vous estimez que donc les
droits des consommateurs sont lésés oui
absolument
comme j'expliquais fera en vertu du code
civil et il n'y a pas de doute à l'effet
que les québécois ont droit à des
remboursements
il n'y a pas de mal à offrir le cri du
voyage cependant est-ce qu'il faut que
les consommateurs puissent avoir le
choix
puis également les crédits voyage s'est
structurée de la même façon qu'un
certificat cadeau une carte cadeau un
certain montant d'argent qui paient à
l'avancé pour se procurer un service
plus tard et depuis 2010 c'est interdit
au québec d'avoir une date d'expiration
sur un certificat cadeau
et là vous allez vous retrouver
potentiellement
le plus gros chèque cadeau que vous
aurez jamais un peu moins vu expirer
dans 24 mois
donc pour nous c'est complètement
inacceptable air canada a levé la date
d'expiration qui enlever certains autres
contraintes mais malgré tout c'est ce à
quoi un crédit-voyage a dû ressembler au
départ donc les cris du voyage c'est pas
un mal mais il faut qu'il faut que les
gens aient l'option d'être remboursé si
le sourire et ça ne vient pas du tout
selon nous en contravention là avec le
fait que les transporteurs aériens soit
deux jours pose la question mais rené
bailly me bats je trouve que vous avez
pas répondu précisément à cette question
là est ce que les compagnies aériennes
qui ont perdu 85 à 100 % de leurs vols
sont capable financièrement de
rembourser des milliards de dollars de
billets d'avions alors vous avez raison
air canada disait il ya quelques
semaines qu'ils ont et trez-hir
trésorerie de 7 milliards de dollars et
en même temps il annonçait que le
premier trimestre ils ont perdu un
milliard de dollars autrement dit ces
trésors bella ne dure pas longtemps
on est d'accord là dessus c'est comme ça
que je disais il faut il faut à la fois
question de remboursement des passagers
mais aussi de l'aide de l'état à
d'autres compagnies aériennes comme on
le fait en europe homologué aux états
unis donc les compagnies ce n'est pas
aux passagers d'assumer ce risque aulas
ce n'est pas aux passagers de se rendre
les compagnies aériennes pérenne au
détriment de leur situation financière
à eux donc c'est ça de la question c'est
celle là où l'état doit intervenir pour
essayer de mettre les citoyens à l'abri
et les compagnies aériennes parlons
l'occasion donc aujourd'hui au jour
d'aujourd'hui les compagnies aériennes
peuvent rembourser en tout cas se prend
le cas d'air canada on peut rembourser
les passagers
vous imaginez que juste avec 2,2
milliards et quelques que air canada
doit ses passagers c'est comme s'ils
pouvaient acheter avec cet argent là
trois roquettes fois air transat
outre un groupe transat c'est quelque
chose qui est inconcevable
ce n'est pas normal qu'on prie les
passagers comme ça encore en train d'en
l'otage et lise thériault est ce qu
ailleurs dans le monde on rembourse les
voyageurs oui tout à fait en europe or à
bours les voyages a déjà beaucoup de
québécois des canadiens qui nous ont
contactés et qui avaient des vols qui
transpire à l'europe
mentionné qu'ils ont reçu un
remboursement aux états unis on a
également ordonné que les consommateurs
aient le choix d'être remboursés ou pas
et si je peux me permettre d'ajouter sur
ce que dit monsieur avant je sais pas
s'ils n'ont plus les compagnies rien on
l'argent pour rembourser mais il devrait
la voir où il devrait y en avoir une
grande partie en ce moment puisque la
loi sur la protection du consommateur au
moins pour les cuvées oblige les
n'importe quel commerçant qu'on fait
plus de deux mois al avance de déposer
les sommes en fidéicommis donc bien sur
les billets d'avion sont pas tous acheté
deux mois la france mais ces sommes-là
devrait en fidéicommis et tout ce qui
passe
une agence de voyage également être
déposés indique me tenir en et brahimi
est ce que les compagnies aériennes
canadiennes pourraient faire faillite
tout à fait tout à fait ça c'est quelque
chose qui est envisageable en tout cas
les plus petits c'est à dire que si par
exemple dans le cas d'air transaction va
pas de l'avant avec les transactions
éclairs canada air transat
je vois très mal comment pourra s'en
sortir dans ces situations là alors air
canada ou encore la trésorerie
relativement vaste mais écoutez quand
ils compagnies comme lufthansa un kit
d'un petit peu le flou rose du bleu de
la ville de la ville sera à travers le
monde
contassot élu raid qui sont gardés par
l'argent des émirs d'arabie ni ils sont
ils sont en situation de faillite
alors nous nous sommes de petits acteurs
à côté de ces compagnies là est tout à
fait la faillite est hélas une fois que
regarder à un milliard de dollars de
pertes ou plus par trimestre les 717
milliards d'air canada un dur à quelques
mois pas plus
bon ben on verra de toute façon le
premier ministre trudeau a annoncé qu'il
aurait qu il aura des choses à annoncer
prochainement on va suivre de près élise
thériault merci mélanie brahimi merci
c'est un plaisir